last questions today Lisa wrote in
saying hey you guys have talked about
acquired tastes before can you talk
about number one case that you have
successfully acquired for things you
used to not like and number two things
you have not been able to acquire a
taste for well the picture we're looking
at here is of a durian fruit this is
something I have not been able to
acquire a taste for in the one time I
tried it on Lewis's last day on the show
he really wanted to bring in and cut
open and sample a durian fruit the smell
was absolutely vile I explain this a few
times it's spelled sort of like a auto
body shop combined with I don't even
know what else and I have not yet been
able to acquire a taste for durian I
have never acquired a taste for eel okay
it really just strikes me as you're
basically eating a snake and I have no
taste for you whatsoever I've never
acquired a taste for sort of exotic
meats like I don't know I I know people
are going to write in and say David
you're not thinking exotically enough
but for me like I wouldn't eat ostrich
I've not acquired a taste for that I've
said I've not i'm not interested in
eating whale or shark certainly not
dolphin uh those are things I've tried
but I have no interest in so I guess you
could say I haven't acquired a taste the
biggest change what I've really acquired
a taste for growing up and basically for
the entire time that sushi started
getting very popular I just could not
see myself eating raw fish I imagine
that the texture would be very very sort
of rubbery and the entire idea of it
really really freaked me out but a
couple of summers ago I had some kind of
raw think it was yellow tail some kind
of raw yellowtail dish and I went into
it very very skittish lien skeptically
and I had I cut like the smallest piece
of this raw yellowtail and I tried it it
was amazing and then I said wow well I i
think i'm gonna try that raw salmon that
people have when they have sushi cuz it
kind of kind of looks good but me I've
always been scared of it and I loved and
now i'm eating raw fish all over the
place i really do like it i do try to
eat not too much uh but I I really have
a qui
to taste for raw fish I'm trying to
think what else uh certainly I i would
say fish in general i know it's very
common that kids don't like fish and in
my family we had fish kinda frequently
and i was always kind of and and i think
part of it was maybe it wasn't prepared
in the best way not to insult anybody in
particular cooking or anything like that
in my household but uh over the last 10
years I probably really acquired much
more of a taste for fish and really a
lot of this could be that I've started
eating less and less red meat to the
point where now I I basically eat red
meat I don't know maybe once every six
weeks or once every two months or
something like that so raw fish is the
answer Lisa I have acquired a taste for
it great questions today keep them
coming we will answer three every Friday
send a min voicemail email Twitter
Facebook read it youtube what else
instagram not so much instagram not the
best venue for questions we've got a
great bonus show coming up for you uh
david pakman.com slash membership is how
you sign up